Traduttore: Andrea Borraccetti
Revisore: Federico MINELLE
“Io mi fido di te”
è una frase bellissima
da dire a una persona
perchè presuppone il fatto
che affideremo a questa persona
i nostri beni più cari, più preziosi.
Affideremo a questa persona la capacità
di decidere al nostro posto,
essendo sicuri che le decisioni prese
sarebbero prese per il nostro bene,
a nostro beneficio.
Voi direste mai “io mi fido di te”
ad una macchina, ad un robot
o a un computer,
per quanto intelligente possa essere?
Gli affidereste
i vostri beni più preziosi,
i vostri dati personali, tranquillamente?
Lo lascereste prendere decisioni
al posto vostro,
essendo sicuri che queste decisioni
vengano prese per il vostro bene?
Beh, oggi proviamo a rispondere
ad una domanda
e la domanda è se
noi siamo in grado di far entrare
nel cerchio della nostra fiducia,
oltre che agli umani, anche delle macchine
e vogliamo anche rispondere alla
domanda se è possibile che queste tecniche
di intelligenza artificiale
di cui abbiamo sentito parlare oggi
in effetti possano essere usate
per il nostro bene, a beneficio nostro,
a beneficio della società
e dell'ambiente in cui viviamo.
Mi occupo di intelligenza artificiale
da più di 20 anni
come docente, ricercatrice e mi occupo
dei sistemi di supporto alle decisioni:
sono dei sistemi che non si
sostituiscono all'uomo,
ma che lo supportano, lo aiutano
a prendere decisioni informate,
propongono scenari alternativi,
valutano costi,
tipicamente cercano di minimizzarli,
valutano impatti.
Questi sistemi devono in qualche modo
esibire una qualche forma d'intelligenza
perché devono ragionare, devono imparare,
devono elaborare
una grande quantità di dati, tipicamente,
e devono anche
adattarsi alle situazioni.
Devono veramente mostrare una
qualche forma d'intelligenza,
la cosiddetta "Intelligenza Artificiale".
Ultimamente sentiamo tanto parlare
di intelligenza artificiale
sui media, social network,
a volte bene, a volte male,
ma perché c'è tutta questa attenzione?
Perché come abbiamo visto
negli interventi precedenti
negli ultimi anni ci sono stati dei
risultati straordinari,
straordinari che fino a qualche tempo fa
non erano assolutamente pensabili.
Qualche esempio: la "visione artificiale".
Fino al 2010, insomma,
8 anni fa, 9 anni fa
le capacità di una persona erano molto
superiori a quelle di un computer.
A fare che cosa? Per esempio
riconoscere quello che c'è
- il contenuto di un immagine,
il contenuto di un video -
eravamo molto superiori; quella linea
rossa che vedete alle mie spalle
sono le performance di un essere umano.
Da quando qualche anno fa sono
state scoperte queste tecniche
di "Deep Learning" che hanno portato
a dei grandissimi risultati,
le performance di una macchina hanno
raggiunto e addirittura superato
la capacità di un uomo
nel riconoscere per esempio il contenuto
di un immagine e descriverla.
Un altro esempio, pensiamo
al "Question Answering".
Il "question aswering" è la capacità di
rispondere a delle domande
estraendo conoscenza da, per esempio,
quello che troviamo sulla rete, dai libri,
dalle enciclopedie, in modo veloce.
È di qualche anno fa la notizia
di una donna giapponese affetta da
una forma molto rara di leucemia
la cui malattia è stata diagnosticata
dal sistema di Intelligenza Artificiale
Watson dell'IBM:
è stata trovata una cura e questo
è ovviamente un ambito in cui
l'intelligenza artificiale porta
benefici all'uomo.
Inoltre l'intelligenza artificiale è
stata usata anche in ambiti
che sono prettamente umani: la creatività.
Questi sono dei dipinti
che sono stati fatti da una macchina
di intelligenza artificiale.
Vedrete qualche somiglianza con dipinti
reali, ma questi sono dipinti originali.
Nella musica, nella scrittura,
risultati straordinari,
ma noi ne abbiamo anche paura:
quando pensiamo all'intelligenza
artificiale a volte ci vengono in mente
degli scenari apocalittici in cui robot
prendono coscienza di sé e ci combattono
per avere il sopravvento
sulla razza umana,
insomma Terminator, Matrix ...
Ma senza andare a
scomodare la fantascienza,
ci sono alcuni usi dell'intelligenza
artificiale che sono dannosi per l'uomo
si pensi alle armi autonome: ci sono
investimenti costanti sulle armi autonome
e qui la decisione da prendere
è se togliere o meno la vita umana
e quindi c'è stata una petizione
poco tempo fa
firmata da circa tremila scienziati
in tutto il mondo
per bandire la ricerca di intelligenza
artificiale nelle armi autonome.
In uno scenario ancora più vicino a noi:
il mondo del lavoro,
si pensa che nel 2030 il 30% dei posti
di lavoro verrà soppiantato
dall'intelligenza artificiale,
da macchine.
E questo ci fa paura ovviamente perché
il mondo del lavoro cambierà
alcune professioni spariranno, altre
verranno radicalmente modificate.
Ne abbiamo paura, ma noi oggi vogliamo
cercare di capire un'altra cosa
se queste tecniche possono
essere usate a beneficio nostro
della nostra società, del nostro
ambiente, vogliamo cioè vedere
sel'intelligenza artificiale può essere
usata nel campo della sostenibilità,
dello sviluppo sostenibile; è uno sviluppo
delle nostre generazioni che non inficia
lo sviluppo delle generazioni future e in
questi ambiti i problemi decisionali
sono veramente complessi, provate
a pensare alla gestione di un ecosistema,
al preservare un ecosistema,
che decisioni dobbiamo prendere,
che cosa dobbiamo investire.
Ma pensiamo per esempio anche a quelli
che si chiamano sistemi socio-tecnici,
sistemi cioè in cui convivono
delle infrastrutture
costruite dall'uomo e l'uomo stesso e
la società;
per esempio le "Smart Cities"
le città del futuro,
per esempio le "Smart Grid"
le reti elettriche del futuro.
Perché sono complesse queste decisioni?
Perché coinvolgono tantissimi fattori:
coinvolgono infrastrutture costruite
dall'uomo, coinvolgono l'ambiente,
coinvolgono fattori economici,
il fattore umano, dinamiche sociali
e prendere decisioni in questi ambiti
è veramente complicato.
L'intelligenza artificiale ci può dare
una mano costruendo modelli:
i modelli sono approssimazioni
della realtà,
ma sono utili per aiutarci
a prendere decisioni
e i modelli sono di tre tipi tipicamente:
modelli descrittivi che descrivono
il sistema su cui vogliamo decidere,
descrivono i suoi componenti e
interazioni tra questi componenti;
modelli predittivi che cercano
di prevedere quella che è
la dinamica futura di un sistema
e modelli decisionali o prescrittivi
che sono quelli
che ci aiutano a prendere decisioni.
Vi farò un esempio:
questo esempio è un esempio in un
problema di gestioni di calamità naturali
ed è un sistema che è stato sviluppato
al NICTA in Australia da un gruppo
capitanato dal prof. Pascal Van Hentenryck
ed è la gestione di un'evacuazione
di un'intera parte di popolazione
in seguito all'esondazione di una diga.
La diga si chiama diga di Warragamba,
sta nella Hawkesbury-Nepean region
e ogni tanto esonda coprendo una
superficie che coinvolge 70.000 persone
in 50 zone residenziali
che devono essere portate in salvo
prima dell'arrivo dell'acqua e
possibilmente con i loro mezzi.
C'è una rete stradale chiaramente per
fare questo, ci sono dei dati storici
per analizzare i fenomeni che sono
successi nel passato
e allora abbiamo i nostri modelli
che ci danno una mano: i modelli
descrittivi che descrivono
la rete stradale, i flussi di traffico
che questa rete riesce a sostenere,
a supportare, abbiamo la densità di
popolazione, abbiamo un sacco di dati
e con questi dati possiamo
estrarre modelli descrittivi.
Poi abbiamo i modelli predittivi
e questa è una simulazione
dell'arrivo dell'acqua
e questa simulazione, una simulazione
che è un modello simulativo,
modello matematico molto complesso, ma ci
dice esattamente, con grande accuratezza,
quando arriverà l'acqua in una certa zona
e quando una strada verrà interrotta
dall'arrivo dell'acqua.
Sulla base di questo modello previsionale,
predittivo,
noi vogliamo costruire
dei piani di evacuazione.
In questo video
noi vediamo due piani a confronto:
questo, il primo è quello
della protezione civile,
diciamo costruito da essere umani
che cerca di portare in salvo le persone
prima dell'arrivo dell'acqua
e prende determinate decisioni,
vedete questi blocchettini verdi sono
insiemi di macchine, gruppi di macchine
però ahimè 11.000 delle 73.000 persone
coinvolte rimangono intrappolate
in zone allagate e quindi dovranno
essere portate in salvo in modi diversi.
Questi sono degli zoom su questo piano
in cui l'acqua arriva
e queste persone non riescono
ad andarsene con i propri mezzi
e capita diciamo su 11.000 persone,
quindi queste decisioni sono state
prese da esseri umani
molto esperti a dir la verità.
Questo invece è la simulazione di un piano
d'evacuazione suggerito
da un sistema decisionale basato sulla
predizione dell'arrivo dell'acqua
che vedete arriva da nord,
dall'alto e riesce a portare in salvo
tutte quante le persone, ma vedete
fa delle cose un po' strane
perché in basso a sinistra fa partire
delle macchine
anche se sono molto lontane
dall'arrivo dell'acqua
perché sa che se non lo facesse
queste rimarrebbero
intrappolate quando l'acqua arriva.
Bello eh? Adesso la domanda però è:
ma le persone si comportano davvero
come noi gli diciamo di comportarsi?
E la risposta è ovviamente no:
c'è il fattore umano da
tenere in considerazione.
Le persone in certe situazioni
si lasciano prendere dal panico,
agiscono in modo irrazionale,
vogliono proteggere i propri cari,
possono agire in modo egoistico.
E allora che cosa dobbiamo fare?
Vi faccio un esempio:
se noi vogliamo liberare una certa zona
e facciamo evacuare le persone
in due momenti diversi della giornata: il
primo la mattina, il secondo il pomeriggio
quelle che restano e che vedono
alcuni che partono
tipicamente si fanno prendere dal panico
e partono anche loro,
creando degli ingorghi
che non si verificherebbero
se partissero quando glielo dice il piano
costruito dal sistema decisionale.
Ma questo è abbastanza normale;
e allora che fare?
Questo fattore umano deve essere
inserito all'interno dei modelli
e quindi modellare anche il fattore umano
oltre che la rete stradale,
l'arrivo dell'acqua.
Noi dobbiamo modellare il fatto che
abbiamo a che fare con delle persone
che agiscono in modo irrazionale.
E poi la domanda più difficile:
supponiamo che proprio questo
piano di evacuazione
che porti in salvo tutti non esista.
Chi lasciate lì?
Un sistema di intelligenza artificiale può
deciderlo e allora deve in qualche modo
mettere su una bilancia le vite umane.
Chi lascio? Chi porto in salvo?
E questo è un fattore etico, d'accordo?
Noi vorremo che quelle decisioni
fossero prese da un sistema
in modo non discriminante,
in modo trasparente, in modo equo,
rispettando i nostri diritti,
la nostra privacy,
Beh, se lo chiedeste a me io prima
di tutto porterei in salvo i bambini,
forse alcuni di voi saranno anche
d'accordo con me, però se voi guardate
c'è un esperimento interessantissimo:
"The Moral Machine" fatto dal MIT
che, partendo dall'esperimento sulla guida
autonoma, riesce a partizionare il mondo
in 5 zone diverse che hanno principi
etici e morali completamente diversi.
Cioè se voi chiedeste a una persona che
vive in Cina o nel sud-est asiatico
se salvare prima un bambino, probabilmente
non salverebbe prima un bambino,
ma una persona anziana, perché la
persona anziana detiene la saggezza
e quindi non salverebbero
probabilmente prima un bambino,
ma allora non esistono
principi etici universali
e quindi come facciamo a modellare
questi principi etici?
Come facciamo a metterli
nei nostri modelli decisionali?
Ed è proprio su questo che
la ricerca si deve concentrare:
i sistemi di intelligenza artificiale
stanno diventano
sempre più potenti, sempre più pervasivi
e come diceva lo zio di
Peter Parker nonché Spider-Man
“da un grande potere,
deriva una grande responsabilità”.
Quindi noi vogliamo in ultima analisi
che i sistemi di intelligenza artificiale
che decideranno per noi,
che decidono per noi
agiscano in modo responsabile, aderendo
ai nostri principi etici e morali.
Chiaramente per far questo la strada è
lunga e ci sono sicuramente due punti
su cui concentrarsi: uno è la ricerca,
cioè noi oltre alla ricerca su fattori
tecnici, metodologici, scientifici,
dobbiamo anche concentrarci
su come inserire fattori umani,
etici e morali all'interno dei modelli
ed inoltre noi abbiamo
anche la responsabilità
di educare delle persone sempre su
questi fattori, anche sull'etica
perché vogliamo che i sistemi decisionali
anche in futuro siano dei sistemi
che agiscano responsabilmente
per cui io possa dire:
"Io mi fido di te"
Grazie
(Applausi)